bonjour monsieur pascal yiacouvakis donc
météorologue à radio canada alors
expliquez nous pascal les changements
climatiques
c'est quoi au juste le changement
climatique c'est le résultat ou de du
réchauffement climatique donc on sait
que le climat se réchauffe et ce
réchauffement provoque des perturbations
climatiques donc provoque le changement
climatique le climat est en train de
changer de se modifier suite au
réchauffement global on parle de
l'échauffement de la balle parce que ça
serait chouette pas partout de la même
manière il ya même des endroits où ça
même ça s'est refroidi un peu mais
globalement ça s'est réchauffée et csu
réchauffement qui provoque justement
lille déséquilibre climatique donc le
changement climatique justement les
déséquilibres c'est le mot au canada
comment ces changements ces
déséquilibres rolland se manifeste-t-il
bas on voit qu'il ya une augmentation
des événements extrêmes par exemple
quand il pleut il pleut plus fort et
plus petits plus intense qu'avant donc
des inondations plus fréquentes peut
avoir de l'autre côté de l'autre extrême
des sécheresses plus intenses qui pour
avoir souvent des feux de forêt des
épisodes de fait penser à un exemple
important des ouragans aussi plus
intense le qui frappent suis
potentiellement peuvent frapper le
canada met donc c'est mon et probables
surtout les états unis sont touchés et
aussi le réchauffement qui s'étale
maintenant beaucoup plus au nord ou dans
l'arctique canadien et température monte
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'ailleurs
donc fonte du pergélisol et tous les
problèmes que sa cause mais aussi les
problèmes de avec la faune on sait par
exemple que les ours polaires ont des
sérieuses ennuis à churchill fait trop
chaud
la banquise se réduit évidemment les
ours polaires rue vont chasser à partir
de la banquise donc évidemment monde
s'ils sont en péril et on voit qu'ils
sont de plus en plus maigres amaigri
souffre énormément
donc ce sont des choses ça c'est
directement lié au changement climatique
qui affectent le canada la banquise qui
se rétrécit le pergélisol aussi c'est un
phénomène assez assez important est
assez grave
oui c'est grave parce que c'est vrai ça
va ça provoque des problèmes pour ce qui
est des inuit qui vivent en ordre les
structures des maisons deviennent
instables carrément parce qu'ils sont
partis sur un sol qui est entré de
dégeler donc il n'y est plus en fait la
paire génie sol n'est ni plus pergélisol
parce que il des jeunes gens
le sol déjà durant l'été donc ça a
provoqué beaucoup de difficultés
beaucoup de problèmes dans ces régions
les populations locales qui sont touchés
là bas les animaux aussi comme vous
disiez l'ours polaire avec la banquise
et les faits qui assurent le reste de la
population au canada kate sont ils des
effets sur la santé par exemple si on
vit une période de canicule ya des gens
qui en meurent de l'achat la pensée des
gens qui sont plus âgés qui sont plus à
risque
la pollution qui augmente les gens qui
ont des problèmes de plus en plus de
problèmes d'asthme donc sont des
problèmes qui sont liés au réchauffement
climatique et donc aussi aux problèmes
des polices la pollution que ça va
ensemble parce que ce qu'il faut ça
qu'ils vont tout le monde le sait c'est
que si les températures immense
essentiellement à cause des gaz à effet
de serre tout à fait et comment ça se
fait que le grand nord canadien et
l'arctique sont plus touchés que le
reste du pays 6 et quel phénomène qui
rend sa alors ce qui se passe dans ces
régions c'est que s'il avoue savoir que
la glace et la neige est ce qu'on
appelle un albédo donc un pouvoir de riz
fier de l'inflexion de radiation du
minime neuze très important la neige
gelée blanche donc elle réfléchit
beaucoup et la lumière à peu près 90% si
cette neige disparaît le réchauffement
beaucoup plus rabais dans ces régions
sont beaucoup plus sensibles au fait que
la neige et à la glace disparaît plus
rapidement donc le réchauffement va se
faire plus rapidement dans ces régions
mais ça va pas et il a fallu seulement
plus jolies danseuses mais c'est que ça
va se réchauffer plus rapidement notre
la variation tempérance le plus
important on sait par exemple le passage
du nord-ouest aujourd'hui ça se fait
avant ça se faisait pour alors il ya des
régions qui sont plus rapidement libre
de glace est ce qu'on doit s'attendre
aussi à plat de plus en plus de
catastrophes naturelles mais de type par
exemple inondations oui exactement feux
de forêt on en parle un peu tantôt donc
ça c'est essentiellement les deux
principaux problèmes qu'ont ville et
sécheresses aussi donc inondations
sécheresses ce feu de forêt vous serez
aussi des tempêtes on ne vous dit en
fait de neige qu'a catastrophique aussi
hilton plus de neige un épisode de neige
peut être plus important qui à l'époque
alors on bat des records fréquemment
c'est un peu tout ça ensemble donc c'est
les événements extrêmes la fréquence
c'est qu'à l'époque il y avait des
événements alors par les assureurs ils
vont vous dire que c'est vraiment ça lui
a coûté pas mal plus cher et tout le
monde va payer pour ce aussi parce que
les primes d'assurance augmentent la
plupart des scientifiques s'accordent
pour dire que les changements
climatiques mot existe il demeure des
sceptiques qu est ce qu un météorologue
comme vous peut répondre aux sceptiques
encore écouter on est un hymne il ya un
consensus de la plupart des
scientifiques alors laisser penser que
je pense qu'ils ont plus souvent
peut-être mal informé ou ne sais pas il
vous faut pas croire qu'on peut dire
c'est que moi personnellement comme soit
sceptique face à ce qui se passe en un
consensus scientifique actuellement et
le menu juste ma chapeaute ces études il
a donc faisait que les sceptiques sont
de moins en moins nombreux tout le monde
le sait mais mais mais mais même
président 30-10 dis pas que le
changement climatique et qui n'existait
pas à l'époque bush non plus dit pas que
ça existait pas mais lui c'est une
question politique de ce côté mais à
tout le monde s'entend pour dire qu'il
est loïc qu'on doit y faire face le tuer
et pour terminer est-ce que vous restez
est-ce que vous gardez de l'espoir ben
moi je suis relativement pessimiste
parce que je vois les choses arriver
trop rapidement
moi ça mais qui ajoute la société sans
change pas assez rapidement à mon goût
je pense que c'est tout le monde de
faire son effort moi je fais mon effort
c'est même quand on fait on dit qu'on
fait une forme c'est même plus un effort
de me balader avec lou dix mois par
année c'est même pas un effort pour moi
c'est un plaisir de marcher d'abandonner
la voiture c'est un plaisir
alors je réponds oui à des formes
simplement un mode de vie on doit
changer notre mode de vie et s'adapter
pour donner une chance à la planète est
pour l'instant à mes yeux ça va pas
assez rapidement c'est passé vite
puis l'idée c'est que ce qu'on fait si
on ya des efforts qui sont faits ne sont
vraiment pas suffisant mais quand on
regarde ce qui se passe dans la nature
là ça va beaucoup plus rapidement on n'a
qu'à regarder saison des ouragans
complètement démentiel connu l'année
dernière on à 2005 c'était on a eu
tellement de tempête qu'on avait même
plus de noms dans la liste
non je mets du sol alors ça va 2005 sait
pas si loin que ça et l'année dernière
on a eu des ouragans meurtriers terrible
des irms assez incroyable maria alors ça
va très rapidement
c'est très rapide des dirigeants doit
relier les excès de plus en plus rapide
je dirais pas qu'on semble tout droit
dans le mur on n'est pas loin il va
falloir se réveiller visite et voilà
qu'on bouge
puis ce que ça passe et une conscience
collective que ça prend carrément il
faut vraiment bouger rapidement le sujet
des choses qui se font mais à mes yeux
se passer prendre conscience déjà fait
prendre conscience mais agir agir par
des gens sont conscients mais il faut
agir
pourquoi j'ai bien je vous dis c'est un
mode de ville se déplace essentiellement
à vélo ou les séries mode de vie simple
aisée pour me marcher ça va ensemble
moi je dis toujours c'est bon pour ton
portefeuille c'est ben beau c'est bon
pour ta santé puis c'est bon pour la
planète de la planète et pour tout le
monde c'est pour compliquer fait ça puis
schalke façon déformée
puis on est bas plus ça ira mieux mais
ça ira tout à fait merci beaucoup pascal
yiacouvakis à bientôt
au revoir